kevin and kim we see you two attempt to
give
something a shot
it does not work out
um well it's a couple shots i think uh
but kim ultimately you were the one who
kind of pulled the plug on this why
couldn't you go there with kevin um i
mean
i'm not gonna point fingers i'm gonna be
very honest i
have a lot of work to do inside you know
when it comes to trust and i just
couldn't
get
past that with him you know even though
i put him through so many tests on the
show um
i tried to you know but i felt like
it didn't feel right towards the end
kevin did you feel led on at all that
was kind of it seemed your frustration
after the uh lie detector test yeah
to be real like i did
do you even really want to be with me
no
as an adult have you ever stolen
anything and got away with it i think
we're good i've never
been
questioned so much about my integrity
and honesty you know and to have
that question not just with kim but
everybody
that that was the most biggest letdown
and that kind of hurt the most i think
everybody knows me the most here like in
the sense like i'm not trying to be
perfect i'm not trying to pretend to be
somebody i'm not like i have many flaws
i'm the first person to tell you that if
i [ __ ] up somewhere i want to know and i
want to see if i can do something better
and if i didn't then
i didn't you know like i i don't know
how to defend myself but when people
don't believe me
even when you go through a lie detective
test and just to find out maybe
some
honesty wasn't being thrown both ways it
feels
feels hurtful
so now i'm gonna ask
the
i don't know i'm going i'm i'm seeking
professional help not because of kim but
i want a better relationship moving
forward with whoever i want to be with
in the future
um and and better friendships too
because uh you know i think therapy uh
helps mental health is great
uh i'm sober for a long time but i think
i'm now at a level of my emotional
sobriety where i want to have therapy to
help me with that other part as well of
my life so that better relationships too
so even though it was a rough moment
growth and some good came out of it
seemingly for both of you
yeah yeah i think i mean it was fun
taking a lie detective test
that man has been on more reality shows
than i think anybody he is on every
reality show doing every lie detector
test this is a question but it's serious
what if all of a sudden you start to
feel like horny or something
you fail
just want to answer all questions in the
same volume and strength i mean the
season kind of ends and i'm like did
they already shoot a season three that's
my big question and a big theme of the
season
is these like wish cards these wish
walls where people leave messages so
let's go around one wish for season
three i wish i could feel more
comfortable in where i'm heading in my
life you know i think that's something
that i've always wanted to feel home
somewhere and feel comfortable with my
career and who i am and uh and place in
life kim after this season what's your
wish my wishes
can everybody just get along
there wouldn't be a show
it wouldn't be a show exactly we've got
a war going on right now i get it but
damn
[Music]
you